plenty of things can't be controlled in
the national football league including
right now the destination
of le'veon bell finally released
yesterday by the new york jets chris
that last ditch effort
to tell the world hey we're going to
release this guy
in other words please call us right now
if you would like to work out a trade
that didn't work
bell is gone and now the question is
where does he land next before we get to
that though
yeah and let me just point out let me
just point out right the reason le'veon
bell isn't subject to waivers
we hear all the time guy was released he
has to go through waivers if you have
four more years of service in the nfl
and you're released at any time between
the launch of the waiver period right
after the super bowl
and the trade deadline the tuesday after
week eight if you're released at any
time in that window
you're automatically a free agent if you
have four or more years of service
right after the trade deadline you must
pass
through waivers so not that anyone was
going to claim le'veon bell's contract
via waivers but it's something to keep
in mind because we're getting closer to
that point
after the tuesday following week 8
november 3rd anyone who gets cut must
pass
through waivers and the best example i
have of that chris this is actually from
before you were even in the nfl in 2002
dion sanders was on the washington
reserve retired list because he wanted
nothing to do with marty schottenheimer
so he retired after one year with the
team
he wanted to get on the raiders
bandwagon the year that they were
heading
to the super bowl eventually to take on
the buccaneers and
daniel snyder accommodated his request
released him from the reserve retired
list it was after the trade deadline
and marty schottenheimer who was then
the coach of the chargers said no no no
no no
no it's not going to be that easy for
you dion i'm claiming you on waivers
and that ended the potential effort by
dion sanders to get on the wash
the oakland bandwagon in 2002. so
waivers not an issue
but soon waivers will be an issue for
anyone who is released well and
i mean the thing don't you feel like
this could be
an explosive trade deadline this year
where there could be a lot of movement
i don't know i'm just throwing this out
there it just feels that way
especially with the pending salary cap
and where it might be
next year you might have teams that are
truly just trying to unload
and prepare for next year who might
think they're kind of out of it or
whatever that is
i i'm interested to see where it goes
too just because we also got
we've got some big time teams who we see
have certain position areas or whatever
that are
truly needed and they're in the super
bowl conversation so
do they make those type of plays to get
that
oh we need that one more guy to put us
over the top
uh i feel like it's it could be an
exciting year as far as that's concerned
and it's something to watch out for here
over the next few weeks
here's a wrinkle to consider and i need
to take a closer look at one of the
many nfl covet 19 protocols because
the the the landing strip to work out a
trade the amount of time the guy has to
spend in the new city
right before he can actually play that
could be a factor i mean think about it
you've got to go through
the testing before you can even have the
physical
what if the physical isn't successful
the trade gets undone
a week later so i think all these things
are going to be moving more quickly than
in the past
i think that the deadline de facto may
be
the tuesday before the usual deadline
but i'll get up to speed on all the
protocols and
at some point over the next week i'll
have a more informed take on when
that moment is going to come for teams
to do deals or not because of the fact
that it's not like any other year where
you just
pull the guy off of one roster and plug
him into another roster the covet 19
protocols which are getting
tighter and more stringent all the time
before they make that something that you
just can't get done so
i i think that that realistically there
could be a lot of movement
but it's going to have to happen well in
advance of the tuesday after a good
point
let's get back to le'veon bell right and
before we talk about where he may go
let's let's just spend a little time
rehashing what happened where he's been
we've talked
from time to time about how the jets did
and didn't use le'veon bell adam gase
here's a question he faced yesterday and
what he said in response to it as it
became obvious
bell was heading out the door
you think he can still be a productive
back in the league
i'm sure he'll get he'll get an
opportunity somewhere else and
you know we'll see what happens
do you agree with the perception that
you misused him
it's irrelevant at this point yeah but i
you know adam
when a team makes a free agent
investment
that large and it ends before two
seasons
i think the fans are interested in
knowing why it didn't work out with a
player of that stature
yeah it didn't work out it didn't work
out and we're gonna focus on this game
right now
now look if that was any other coach it
was bill belichick kyle shanahan anybody
who's been
successful we'd say yeah hey make sense
why are we going to spend time
worrying about why something that didn't
work out didn't work out you got to move
forward we're on to cincinnati
with adam gates the problem is a
question like that and a response like
that gives his critics even more fodder
oh
oh what a you know i saw it all over
twitter yesterday oh this is ridiculous
what can you say it's irrelevant well
it is irrelevant it is irrelevant
because you know what the jets have
four games left until they're by and i
don't see a win
among those four games it's miami
buffalo new england and kansas city not
necessarily in that order
before they go into their bye week they
were going to buy 019 it's bye to
to adam gase so i think that's one of
the reasons why they didn't hold on to
him
pending an injury elsewhere where they
could have suddenly created a trade
market
i think adam gase wanted to rip this
band-aid off in one motion
and move on without this headache
without this distraction without this
issue in the hopes of winning a game
starting with the easiest of the next
four games the miami dolphins on sunday
yeah well i mean i think you're right i
mean we talked about it a little the
other day
it was one of those things where i just
think you know abandoned ship abort
mission whatever that may be
because i think it had reached to that
point where le'veon bell had
was was gonna force them into a position
to where he was gonna make it an issue
and they were gonna have to talk about
it on a daily basis and he's gonna send
out
you know be on social media and hint at
oh i'd like to get the hell out of new
york and get it away from the jets i
mean that's what we saw
and i think right now the jets who are
trying to build something
are trying to get a culture here where
everybody's together and everything
you know is on the up and up but
unfortunately that's just not the case
and i don't know if that's going to turn
around right now or not
certainly i'm skeptical yeah i mean
le'veon bell
uh is it relevant right now to whether
he worked yeah no
not necessarily but i think in the big
picture of adam gates this is something
that
he's going to always have to answer for
unfortunately and it's not
his fault that's the other thing we
always have talked about
this was the prior regime spending way
too much money on a guy that
nobody else was going to pay that type
of money i mean you and i both know
from other teams that nobody offered him
anything
close to what he got other than the new
york jets offers we were told right were
eight nine million types a year
they got played that way so now he gets
forced to get a guy where
he's the fantasy lover right pittsburgh
steelers le'veon bell
stat stat stats well the team stinks
around him
he can't just make it all about le'veon
bell on the offensive side of the ball
le'veon bell's had his own issues too of
staying healthy and being right that way
too
and it's more than just about not being
able to use them it's about a team
that has not been able to set up or set
up
the right way to use anybody to this
point they're so bad and so
dysfunctional on their roster so
yes it stinks i wish they would have
used them better i wish le'veon bell
would be better too
um but i don't know where this goes here
i'm excited to see who gets interested
in the le'veon bell market here over the
next 24 hours
let's be clear about what happened with
the jets and yeah
well and we've talked about this before
right mike mc cagnan the former gm of
the team who was still there when adam
gase was hired so there was this awkward
three-month overlap or so with gase and
mccagnan working together macagnan was
building the team from the outside
in joe douglas is trying to build the
team from the inside out
because le'veon bell isn't going to do
anything for you if you can't block for
him le'veon bell isn't going to do
anything for you if you don't have a
quarterback
that you feel good about in the passing
game which means you need to have
receivers in tight ends that can get it
done
le'veon bell isn't the guy you start
your offense with he's the guy you
finish your offense with he's not barry
sanders
no one is right who can get his hundred
yards even if he's got
nothing around him which for most of his
career in detroit
barry sanders didn't have much around
him but he still was able to gain yards
and make things happen that's not
le'veon bell especially after taking a
year off
so you throw on top of that
the dynamic that they got grifted they
got lied to
they got sold a bill of goods that the
ravens were in this thing for the same
amount or close to the same amount that
the jets ultimately paid 13.5 million a
year
over the first two years fully
guaranteed 27 million no one else
was even in the eight-figure
stratosphere no they were not 49ers were
lurking what around eight in the event
the price fell right and if the jets
said no thank you
he may have been a 49er chris right if
he would have been willing to play for
eight instead of gotten stubborn and
said i'm gonna wait and see if the
market increases that's just the reality
of the running back market yeah but the
jets got
duped they did a bad deal and the
problem is and i think this first went
sideways
when it came out that gates didn't want
bell at that number because it was
twisted as
gates didn't want bell at all no he
didn't want bell at that number
because he knew number one it was more
than anyone was going to pay and number
two
they don't have the rest of the offense
to justify this luxury
it's like having a ferrari and nowhere
to drive it right right
that's what it was yeah right and and
that's that's why it ended up falling
apart
in retrospect no i think that's that's i
think you hit you know the nail on the
head there really i think you explained
it
just right and yeah you're right about
the contract situation everything like
that i mean listen
adam gase he's got friends all over
football i'm sure he had a pretty
idea of what le'veon bell was being
offered at and things like that
and you know from from both our
knowledge i know mine especially
what happened with levion bell is a
bunch of teams kind of got involved out
of nowhere
late in the process because they started
to hear wait you can sign them for 8
million a year
we can get them for 8.5 a year and a
bunch of teams got involved and also the
jets came in and said here's 13
nobody else is offering it but here you
go we'll give you five extra million
dollars compared to everybody else
so yes that was an issue and then mike i
think you're right about the football
aspect of it
you know the beauty of le'veon bell and
what he does and what he did in
pittsburgh was
yeah they had an offensive line of
course he's a really good runner
right so now they're moving people he's
running it's four and five yards and six
and eight and he's making all these
great runs
teams start to go we gotta worry about
the run right then all of a sudden
big ben's in the shotgun there's nobody
in the backfield now le'veon bell's over
at the slot
you know slot receiver because the other
team's got three linebackers in the game
because they just got their face smashed
in by le'veon bell in the run game
and now it's a mismatch because oh crap
we got some 255 pound linebacker
covering le'veon bell in space
and we're going to lose so if you don't
have some of those things that you're
talking about right
the pieces of the formula the right way
the formula is not going to work
and that's ultimately what led to the
demise there
you know you look at the stats last year
they're not good
they're not horrible i mean 750 yards
you know rushing 460 receiving
yeah it's horrible for le'veon bell they
tried to use them as what i'm saying
that you get to see from those stats
it's just there's no success there's
nothing to bite onto as a defense or
really worry about or anything like that
and that just caused the snowball effect
of everything being an issue there
and one name you didn't mention antonio
brown they had him in his prime well
they had lesbian bell in
his prime and ben roethlisberger in his
prime it makes it a lot easier
for each guy individually to get it done
and you know i
i think i believe and you may be
able to even say that i know that uh
gates knew what the market was
for le'veon bell yeah and mccagnan
wasn't
mccagnan wasn't do you want to hear it
right the reasons that's one of the
reasons why mctagnan got fired
after the 2019 draft and now can they
hold it together
long enough to just do anything to make
jets fans think that they have something
positive there we'll see
let's move forward because now here we
are both antonio brown and le'veon bell
are available to anyone who would like
to sign them of course bell's got an
impediment for the next few weeks but
we're not far away from the point where
his suspension is served
and who knows where he goes maybe they
join up again somewhere
bell is the first one on to the market
and look how quickly leonard fernett got
signed you know we had earl thomas
who's still waiting for the phone to
ring which confirms to all those out
there who would insist he's a top 10
safety
he's not a top 10 safety or he'd be on a
team thank you mike cornett was only out
there for a couple of days
before it trickled out that the patriots
were interested and that created
the the mad rush to get leonard
fournette
and you know what maybe if we get a
report today that the patriots should
levy on bell someone else will sign him
today
but chris let's take a look at the teams
out there apparently
points bet had some odds
for the next landing spot that were
taken down which means maybe someone at
point's bed has some inside information
as to where this is heading but the
bears the favorites at plus 450
followed by the eagles chiefs cardinals
bills steelers
patriots a lot longer odds than i think
they should be
89ers at plus 1500 let's start with the
49ers you got kyle said yesterday
i'm good with our guys right they've got
raheem mostert healthy kevin coleman's
coming back
soon jared mckinnon is getting it done
whatever interest they may have had
in early 2019 shanahan made it clear
yesterday and we know that coaches from
time to time
do the sleight of hand so they can maybe
get a guy signed at better terms than
they otherwise would have to pay but
shanahan made it clear yesterday
that's not going to be a landing spot
for le'veon bell and i don't know that
le'veon bell would want to join that
team right now right given that they're
two and three with all those injuries
and this seven game death march that's
coming up for the 49ers
i think that'd be one of the first ones
to scratch off your list if you're
looking for a contender i i agree i mean
i i think he's got to look at
you know it's got to be a contender and
a place where he really feels like he
can be set up for success because like
we said a little yesterday if he has
another if he goes to one of these teams
here
and then goes nah we all just go hey man
he's not the same levion bell it's just
not the same
like we talked about next year he'll be
playing for a very low number
and it'll be a year where it's like hey
you gotta prove you can still play in
this league and it's gonna be like a
make it or break it type of year for him
if this year doesn't end up well i mean
the bear certainly makes sense
i would caution le'veon bell on that one
though
because that could be one of those where
yeah they might be in the playoff
conversation but they can't block people
in the run game he might not be set up
for success there that might not be the
place you want to go
you know the team i keep coming back to
you know i've heard the dolphins are
interested
we hear the name of the patriots i would
think the patriots would have interest
there
it makes sense for their football team
in a lot of ways first off we know
they're a run first team right now
and a run first team with this
versatility guys that running back along
along also is sony michelle's always
hurt
he has a knee issue i don't know if it's
ever going to go away it's looking like
it's one of those knee issues that will
always be there
and he's just going to have to manage it
to extend his career
now they got guys like rex burkhead
and you know damien harris from alabama
and of course le'veon bell to me he fits
with what they want to do in the offense
oh we're in the shotgun it's power
run game oh fake to burkhead here you go
le'veon bell you go this way
oh now the next play instead of burkhead
and le'veon bell being next to me
they're at slot receiver because they're
both phenomenal at that
it fits within their attack let alone
they need running backs so i could
really see new england
at least being interested in this one i
think for the most part
teams that have a pretty good running
back room
we'll probably just go ah we're not sure
about it we don't want to deal with it
we'll let somebody else figure that out
and the patriots clearly could use the
production of le'veon bell their leading
rusher sony michelle
has 173 yards through four games their
number two rusher is cam newton with
149. burkhead 128 damian harris with a
hundred
so they could definitely use them that
you know that they'd be concerned about
le'veon bell's reputation
or i i don't know what i don't know what
it's cause here look
you go to new england you've got the
patriot way you've got bill belichick
and you've got cam newton
i think the presence of cam newton would
also help influence le'veon bell to do
what he's supposed to do and the way the
patriots do
things it's a low risk it's
a one strike if it works it works if it
doesn't we're just going to move on now
look he gets to keep everything that
he's due to make from the jets even
though
his guaranteed money has offset language
he can exercise his right under the cba
to treat the balance of his salaries
termination pay so bell gets the full
six million dollars
unreduced by anything he earns elsewhere
so he can take as little as he wants or
as much as he wants with another team
and it's all
it's all bonus money at this point this
is about setting himself up
for next year this is about resetting
the market for him
and creating the kind of attractiveness
right that would get somebody to pay him
eight you know eight million if he gets
eight million a year this time around
he's doing pretty well because that's
where the market was for melvin gordon
last year we'll talk about him in a
second but
yeah this is more about finding a place
where you're playing into january
pursuing a championship and setting
yourself up
for making a market
that will pay you in a year where the
salary cap's going to be as low as 175
million no
no doubt about it i think that it's it's
got to be in his mind here because
for the the betterment of his career at
least yes and you know you talk about
the patriots
it's amazing when you say all those you
know who leads the team in rushing cam
newton's second
you know there's they're the second
leading they're the second leading
running team in all of football
so that just tells you it is running
back by committee and a bunch of
versatile pieces you could do everything
i think he would fit there you know and
the other thing i think that's
interesting
i you look at some of the other teams
that were on that list kansas city
i mean they got to be thinking about
le'veon bell i just would be shocked
i don't know why they wouldn't he's
clyde edwards hilaire just like in a
different body is a
just the bigger version here oh he can
catch the ball out of the backfield and
run the ball and make people miss
he just got the size element to it you
know also
buffalo bills you know that's another
one i look at just to go
man he'd fit your offense put him out of
receiver
oh hey we got four receivers in the game
go bomb deep everybody oh wait we got
le'veon bell back here it's a draw play
oh watch him boo boo boom and
he would fit with what they do that's
why i think it's very intriguing this
le'veon bell conversation because i
think a lot of the major players here
as far as playoffs are concerned have a
have a little bit of a need for the
position
and you wonder whether to what extent
he'd be attracted to
go with a team that competes
head-to-head with the new york jets to
the extent that he'd like to stick it
oh i'd chat a little bit the bills and
the patriots would give him that option
you mentioned the chiefs and clyde
edward de lair he had such a great game
right out of the gates 25 carries 138
yards 5.2
5.52 yards per attempt he hasn't been
the same guy since then
no he had 38 yards on 10 carries
in the overtime win over the chargers
3.8 yards per carry 20 carries for 64
yards
3.2 against the ravens he's averaged
four yards to carry exactly each of the
last two
games 16 for 64 and 10 for 40. this
isn't the guy that we thought he was
gonna be right
right out of the gate no it's not and
and they they
were interested in le'veon bell last
year when bell
was being dangled in trade they were
interested in adrian peterson
when he was cut by washington not long
before the start of the season
but they wanted to wait until after the
first game of the season peterson wanted
to be on a roster week one
and he joined the lions instead the
openings there the windows there damien
williams opted out and they never really
properly replaced damien williams i
think that there is something to be said
for le'veon bell joining the chiefs and
of all the teams that are in play if the
chiefs are in play that's the one that
is most likely to get to the super bowl
and win it
and give le'veon bell that that uh super
bowl ring that he's never won you think
he came from pittsburgh he has a ring no
they they haven't won one
since the 2008 season a lot of those
guys
on that roster uh other than ben
roethlisberger i'd say there's no one
left on that roster
yeah that that won a super bowl
especially in the heyday of uh
bell and brown and and roethlisberger so
yeah i think that the chiefs have extra
attractiveness
to bell because they give him the best
chance to get a super bowl ring
something he's never he's never even
played in one
i think so i think they'll know how to
use them in the past game he could bring
an element there
you know clyde edwards hilaire's there's
a little bit of a smaller guy le'veon
bell's gonna be a better pass protector
than he
is you know it'd be a nice little
one-two punch to where you don't really
have to change your offense except
we can do the same thing except oh you
know on these guys when levion's in
we got a little bit more power maybe we
do that you know kansas city's not a
great run team
they don't do a lot in the run game it's
really like they run the same two or
three run plays
all game just to kind of keep you honest
and you know keep you
thinking about the run a little bit and
edward solaire
is quick and everything he is the one
thing that i get a little concerned with
is just his
straight speed you know he's one of
those guys mike sometimes that
so quick he makes a guy miss and then
he's in the process of making the second
guy miss and the first guy he made miss
comes back and catches him because he
doesn't really run away from people all
the time
that'd be one flaw i see in this game
but yeah that i mean le'veon bell would
certainly fit
that system and how he would work the
other one mike
that i just think is worth the topic of
conversation because i like the team and
we like the quarterback and what he's
doing right now
is the seahawks you know i always look
at them and go
when chris carson's not in the game
they're not the same football team
that's always i always look at it like
that he changes the way you
view them and it changes them as a team
altogether i feel like when he is out of
the game everybody just plays past
because everyone's like ah
these running backs who really cares
about them that'd be another one where
i'd be
man you let russ cook you got a guy like
levy on bell i think he could fit up
there too to
to a degree and i would think they could
handle his personality just like in new
england and all those type of things as
well
to maybe where he'd be excited about
that carson's got a high of 80 yards
this year
yeah rushing uh so he's not having a
huge year and the question is would they
commit
you know they have completely
transformed their offense from run run
run run run to let russ cook and hey you
make le'veon bell a target in the
passing game he's gonna get his yards
from scrimmage one way or the other he's
gonna get him as a runner he's gonna get
him as a receiver and that would
to the extent that everyone now regards
dk metcalf as the new calvin johnson and
jerry rice combined into one body
you're gonna have some openings
underneath if you send dk metcalf down
the field and there's le'veon bell
and it becomes pick your points that's
what i'm facing the seattle seahawks
exactly we'll see how we'll see how
serious they are about going all in
if they get in this in this chase for
le'veon bell as well but he's gonna have
some options
and i think it makes sense to try to
put himself in a position like i said
play in january when most of the other
teams are home
watching you play well try to win a
super bowl and carry that momentum
into the off season where you can get
one more
bite at the contractual apple before the
sun sets on your useful life as a
running back in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports